Не прорив і не перезавантаження, а спроба зробити відносини США і Росії
менш токсичними - ось головна мета зустрічі Джо Байдена та Володимира Путіна у Женеві,
вважають експерти та оглядачі. Розмова, як прогнозують, буде відвертою,
але прохолодною. Путін прагне домовитися про зони впливу
і залишити у своїй орбіті Україну, але "зради" з боку Байдена і кулуарних угод не буде,
запевняє американський дипломат Чарльз Купчан. Коли почалася війна на Донбасі,
він працював спецпомічником президента США Барака Обами і часто бував у Києві та Москві.
Я впевнений, що президент Байден як людина, яка надзвичайно підтримує Україну,
не збирається вести розмову з Путіним за рахунок суверенітету та добробуту України.
Байден сказав би: "Ні, дякую!" Бо він справді дуже переймається Україною.
Коли я працював у Білому домі за президентства Обами, я шість разів літав в Україну
разом із віце-президентом, який зараз став президентом.
Він був постійно на телефоні з українським президентом та українським прем'єр-міністром.
Він глибоко піклується про довгостроковий добробут України.
Тож думка, що якимось чином він міг би торгуватися з Путіним, щоб продати Україну,
я думаю, що це просто неможливо.
Важко побачити якийсь прогрес на Донбасі, поки не відбудеться зміна у ставленні Росії.
І це буде важко, оскільки Путін, швидше за все, заперечить, що Росія є частиною конфлікту.
І якщо він це зробить, я сподіваюся, що Байден відповість: "Слухай, Володимире,
ми з тобою не можемо мати серйозних робочих стосунків,
якщо ти будеш поводитися зі мною, як з ідіотом".
Опитані DW американські експерти також не вважають "зрадою"
певну зміну позиції Вашингтона щодо "Північного потоку-2" після недавніх заяв держсекретаря США.
Ентоні Блінкен сказав, що завершення цього газогону - вже "доконаний факт"
і нові санкції не вплинули б на фізичне завершення добудови труби.
Тож США вирішили поки не запроваджувати санкції проти компанії Nord Stream 2 AG
та її директора Маттіаса Варніґа.
У Сполучених Штатах - явна опозиція проти "Північного потоку-2". Двопартійна опозиція.
Адміністрація Байдена не хоче, щоб цей трубопровід розвивався.
І я знаю, що зараз у Вашингтоні впливові німецькі політики.
З ними тривають переговори щодо потенційної угоди, яка обмежила б здатність Росії
тиснути на Україну. Це, я думаю, головне занепокоєння у Вашингтоні
- не стільки трубопровід, скільки здатність Росії використовувати його як важіль впливу.
Адміністрація Байдена, можливо, зробила неправильний крок, не запроваджуючи санкції
проти очільника "Північного потоку-2" та різних російських структур, пов'язаних з ним,
але вони завжди мають можливість відповісти санкціями пізніше.
Вони просто вирішили в цей момент цього не робити. Але вони можуть переглянути
це рішення у певний момент. Тож вони не позбулися всіх своїх важелів впливу.
І я думаю, що Байден так вчинив, намагаючись відродити трансатлантичні відносини
і не дати Росії розділити США та Німеччину.
Можна припустити бачення відносин з РФ Байденом: гаразд, давайте поки відкладемо ці важкі питання.
Давайте подивимось, чи не можемо ми знайти спільну мову у питаннях,
що становлять взаємний інтерес. А потім, можливо, пізніше після того,
як ми досягнемо хоч якоїсь довіри, після того, як ми покращимо наші відносини,
ми зможемо вирішити такі жорсткі питання як Україна.
У Києві наразі жодних проривів від зустрічі Байдена і Путіна не очікують.
Головне сподівання - що американський президент чітко пояснить Путіну, що буде,
якщо він і надалі порушуватиме міжнародне право, втручатиметься у вибори
в інших державах та нехтуватиме правами людини у себе в країні.
За словами аналітика Центру "Нова Європа" Сергія Солодкого,
Байден запропонує Путіну "санкційне меню", в якому може бути відключення
від платіжної системи SWIFT, інші фінансові обмеження, а також ще більш
дошкульні санкції проти найближчого оточення Путіна.
Точкове обрання людей, які його оточують, і таким чином непрямо впливати на політику Путіна,
щоб, грубо кажучи, створити навколо нього коло людей, які будуть не задоволені
його політикою, оскільки вони фінансово, політично будуть страждати
від російської агресії, агресії Путіна у зовнішній політиці.
Після зміни влади у Білому домі Сполучені Штати намагаються сформувати
нову стратегію дій щодо Донбасу, щоб підтримати територіальну цілісність України
не тільки на словах, а й на ділі. Сполучені Штати будуть діяти вже без трампівської двозначності
у цьому питанні, але зміна нормандського формату навряд чи відбудеться
у короткостроковій перспективі, вважають експерти.
Поки що ми не бачили політичної волі США на вищому рівні долучатися до переговорного процесу.
Я так розумію, що США не вірять у швидке вирішення і готовність Росії до врегулювання
і, відповідно, не хочуть ув’язуватися у такий тривалий процес, який не веде до суттєвого результату.
Напевно, Байден висловить тверду позицію США щодо необхідності врегулювання ситуації,
щодо дотримання Росією зобов’язань і перед Україною, і міжнародного характеру.
В переговорний процес, у трикутник чи п’ятикутник, де б брала участь американська сторона,
я наразі не вірю. США однозначно на різних рівнях будуть це питання просувати,
порушувати і намагатися урезонити Росію на двосторонньому рівні.
Байден зустрінеться з Путіним у Женеві після участі у самітах Великої сімки і НАТО.
Це правильна послідовність, вважає голова Мюнхенської конференції з безпеки Вольфґанґ Ішинґер.
По-перше, я вважаю, що це дуже розумно - з точки зору дипломатичної практики.
І це єдиний спосіб - спочатку зустрітися з партнерами по НАТО і з партнерами по ЄС
- до зустрічі з Володимиром Путіним. Тільки уявіть, які теорії змови це б породило,
якби він вирішив спочатку зустрітися з Путіним, а вже потім повідомити полякам,
французам і німцям, про що він з ним домовився або не домовився.
Німецький дипломат не очікує суттєвих результатів від зустрічі Байдена з Путіним,
але сподівається, що після цього саміту Вашингтон і Москва знову почнуть обговорювати
такі важливі теми як безпека кіберпростору, контроль над озброєннями,
стратегічна стабільність, торгівля і, звісно, війна в Україні.
Я сподіваюся, що ця зустріч принаймні відкриє шлях для хоча б мінімального відновлення довіри.
Довіра - це те, що повністю було відсутнє у відносинах між США і Росією
протягом останніх кількох років, так само, до речі, як і у відносинах між Росією та Європою.
Ця довіра повністю випарувалася. Ми більше не довіряємо одне одному.
Думаю, що зустріч Байдена і Путіна може стати принаймні першою
маленькою цеглинкою процесу відновлення.
Своє турне по Європі Байден розпочав з жорсткого попередження Москві,
заявивши, що Вашингтон рішуче відповість на дії Росії, які завдають шкоди США
та їхнім партнерам. За словами оглядачів, Байден хоче, з одного боку,
послабити напруженість у відносинах з Кремлем,
а з іншого - посилити тиск, щоб приборкати авантюризм Путіна.